[Music]
hey everyone thanks for joining us for
another episode of I got a question my
name is Aubrey and today's question is I
think I'm addicted to Christian videos I
binge watch Christian content and fool
myself into thinking I'm doing something
healthy or good I always want to read or
watch something and when I don't I feel
craving I'm tired of it and I wonder if
it's common to get hooked on Christian
content in an addictive manner what
should I do so thank you for that
question it's a good one to ponder as we
all travel this journey with Christ we
want to learn more about the Bible and
about him but too much of a good thing
can also be a bad thing we want to have
balance so how do we navigate that I
would suggest to use God's promises and
pray to him for help whenever we have a
craving or Temptation if you truly are
um struggling with temptation or an
addiction you can use his promises to
identify with them to calm you down and
to actually get over those moments I
think we've all identified with that and
it can really help number two sometimes
learning a different way of engaging
with content can be good instead of
watching videos all the time we can
listen to them while you do other things
such as other tasks or go on a walk with
it or even take your Bible out and
follow along that those are good ways
that you can actually interface with it
differently and God can touch your heart
more than just absorbing the information
and letting it be regurgitated to you
platform that we recommend that you can
listen to audio on of different sermons
or presentations would actually be
audioverse.org
number three we can create boundaries
for ourselves use media if it is on
YouTube or what have you as a reward
system
only use it maybe after you've
accomplished a list of things or met a
certain amount of goals so that when you
come down to it at the end of the day
and you've completed those things you
can have maybe an extra 30 minutes that
you give yourself otherwise maybe you
reward Yourself by giving yourself an
extra two hours on
Sundays that way your week is very
productive number four this is having an
accountability partner if you can find
someone who understands and can keep you
accountable hopefully they are in the
same boat so that you feel equally
understood and there for one another you
can actually talk to them pray for one
another and tell them what you're going
through and uplift each other with Bible
verses as well so we need to understand
and be realistic as humans that when we
cut something out of our Lives we need
to fill it with good things otherwise it
will come back and manifest itself self
even greater and we don't want to have
other things come up and become kind of
substitute
addictions as always thank you for
watching and please if you have other
questions feel free to reach out to us
you can either reach out through our
social media accounts or email us on our
website until next
time
[Music]